ciao mariners e benvenuti il nuovissimo
b
idea che mi segue su instagram sa che
oltre alle unghie estranee alle torte
strane ogni tanto così per non saper né
leggere né scrivere pubblico dei video
di bonazzi pescati sul web di questi
ragazzi ce n'è uno in particolare che ha
fatto innamorare migliaia ma ti dico
migliaia milioni di persone sul web ve
lo presento mi si chiama jacob non so
molto su di lui ma possiamo cercare
jacob è nato il 3 aprile del 2000 in
germania è anche già qui mi sento
vecchissima il ragazzo sembrerebbe
essere single ci basta possiamo andare
avanti con il primo video qui e insieme
al suo migliore amico che fa parte
sempre di quel gruppo degli elevator
boys
ecco non mi fa impazzire come fanno
questi balletti di qui perché mi
sembrano un po cioè così un po bambini
però diciamo che in questo momento è
così denudati vanno bene anche se con i
bollettini stupidi secondo me no a
proposito di addominali lui decide bene
di iniziare il video con un'inquadratura
dei suoi dominarli che prontamente copre
guarda in camera canticchia che gli
dobbiamo dire a jacob che gli dobbiamo
dire ecco qui invece lui lui è in
versione sor fissa quindi lui poggia la
tavola da surf guarda in camera guarda
ovviamente noi lo stiamo guardando e
inizia prontamente a togliersi la muta e
ci lascia così col fiato sospeso perché
si scopre solo una spalla quindi
non ci dà tanto ma ci dà qualcosa qui
invece siamo in piscina siamo piscina
lui sta pulendo ah no scusate non
sapendo vicina st raccattando la palla
da basket che gli è caduta
giustamente lo vedo un po impacciato con
questo raccatta mento della palla ma
ovviamente fatto apposta poi per
guardare in camera e tirare l'addominale
e va bene così
se vi cade una palla in piscina da
qualche parte lo chiamiamo ecco qui c'è
lui davanti al frigo probabimente sta
scegliendo cosa mangiare per colazione
tira fuori una tazzina
e lo so ci invita a mangiare insieme a
lui però anche qui a tazzina voi l'avete
vista
cosa c'è in frigo l'avete visto ma ecco
qui invece siamo in spiaggia tanti di
voi quando pubblico questi video mi
dicono sì vabbè ma è un po un po troppo
kringe
concordo nel senso che
quando fanno questi balletti qui un
pelino mi scende
però non lo so non so che di cioè
ammiriamo comunque poi fatemi sapere se
per voi sono kringe o se vi andrebbe
bene che lui facesse qualsiasi cosa lo
guardereste comunque ecco qui
praticamente loro escono dalla stanza
d'hotel giustamente jacob ci guarda cioè
mi guarda perché questo mento sovrano il
video quindi lavorando ma ragazzo mi
dispiace mi guarda e mi sorride ecco non
so voi ma io quando vado negli alberghi
e sono tanti anni che ovviamente
frequento alberghi non ho mai visto
nessuno come lui guardarvi e sorridere
ma solo gente antipatica
anziana e sicuramente non
appetitosa ed è qui che amiamo lo che
c'è qui siamo a new york siamo a new
york lui un po danny zucco lui pronto
per il remake di grease e ci guarda così
in slow motion
vuol dire tutto vuol dire niente di chè
comune era la macchina dietro non
l'avete vista ragazze perdete così
l'attenzione dai ecco qui invece siamo
in metro giustamente in metro come negli
alberghi io non so voi ma non è che
mai avuto un colpo di fulmine che
raramente
perché ecco nelle metro che prendiamo
noi tutti i giorni non sale un jacob
così random a caso e soprattutto entra
ci guarda ci guarda e lì nasce proprio
la storia d'amore tra di noi ecco qui
stiamo per prendere la metro tutti e due
cavolo la perdiamo lui mi guarda io lo
guardo che dobbiamo fare aspettiamo la
prossima insieme ci tocca cito purtro
purtroppo ci tocca
cioè preferivo prendere la metro e
perché poi arrivò in ritardo e tutto
però se proprio devo aspettare la
contesa rossa sacrificio jacob
ecco qui si apre l'ascensore esce lui
sorride che gli dobbiamo dire
che dobbiamo dire
niente ecco concluderà il video con
forse uno dei suoi video più hard perché
lui è in bagno
a petto nudo e si atteggia come un adone
greco e se lo può forse anche permettere
e così lui ci lascia così
con questa sensazione di
come dire di confusione ecco noi
corriamo questo video siamo confusi ma
felici perché sappiamo che lui
continuerà a portare questi contenuti e
non continueremo a guardarli avere un
saluto a jacko fatemi sapere quale in
questo video vi ha smosso di più vi ha
emozionato di più nel profondo circa col
prossimo video vi mando un bacione ciao